>> A STORY IN FIVE WORDS.
>> Dana: HERE'S A STORY IN
FIVE WORDS.
MOST AMERICANS SEIZE THE DAY.
THE NEW POLL SHOWS TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICANS HAVE A CARPE DIEM OR
SEIZE THE MOMENT ATTITUDE.
DO YOU LIVE THIS WAY?
>> I WAS COMPLETELY CONFUSED BY
THIS STORY.
I THOUGHT SEIZE THE DAY MEANT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COME YOUR WAY
AND DO WHAT YOU CAN TO MAKE
YOURSELF IN YOUR WORLD BETTER.
BUT NO, IT'S ADVOCATING DAY
DRINKING, AS FAR AS I CAN TELL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING YOURSELF
FEEL BETTER IN SELF-CARE.
I REMAIN CONFUSED BUT NOT
SURPRISED THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
PROBABLY UNDER THE AGE OF 40
ANSWERED YEAH, I DEFINITELY
SEIZE THE DAY.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY SAID IS THE SINCE THE
PANDEMIC IN ORDER TO MAKE
YOURSELF FEEL BETTER AND FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE LIVING AS YOU DO A
LOT OF ONLINE SHOPPING.
>> I DID THAT BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
THE PERCENTAGE OF 25% DRINKING,
CHOOSING YOUR FAVORITE BEVERAGE,
I'VE BEEN DOING THAT SINCE I WAS
16.
THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT CHANGED MY
LIFE WHATSOEVER OTHER THAN THE
FACT THAT MADE ME ENJOY THE FACT
THAT I GOT TO SOCIAL DISTANCE
FOR TWO YEARS.
I'VE ALWAYS DONE THAT BUT
NORMALLY --
>> Dana: YOU HAD A GOOD
EXCUSE.
>> AND I'M JUST FOLLOWING THE
LAW.
>> Dana: JOEY, DO YOU SEIZE
THE DAY?
>> ONE DAY AT A TIME.
ON A MORE SERIOUS NOTE,
GRATITUDE.
MY HOUSE, MY FORTRESS OF
SOLITUDE.
MY FORTRESS OF GRATITUDE.
I AM SO THANKFUL TO BE ALIVE.
NOT JUST BECAUSE I'VE SURVIVED
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAVE
KILLED ME BUT IN DOING SO I WAS
REMINDED OF HOW BLESSED I AM NOT
JUST TO HAVE MY BEAUTIFUL FAMILY
AND THOSE BLESSINGS BUT JUST BE
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT BEING SAID, THE REASON
THESE YOUNGSTERS ARE LIVING
CARPE DIEM.
IF THE GOVERNMENT WAS ABOUT TO
PAY OFF HALF MY STUDENT LOANS
MIGHT BE TAKING SPRING BREAK IN
CABO TOO.
THERE IS NO BETTER TIME IN
HISTORY HAVE EVER TO BE YOUNG
AND BROKE THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL DO ANYTHING.
>> Dana: DESPITE WHAT JIMMY
SAID IN THE GREEN ROOM, WE ARE
GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
JIMMY, DO YOU ENJOY LIFE'S
PLEASURES MORE POST-PANDEMIC?
>> ACTUALLY KNOW.
I USED TODAY DRINK MORE WHEN I
WAS YOUNGER.
MY TAXI PASSENGERS HATED IT.
I DEFINITELY THINK I CAME INTO
THIS WITH THE SAME ATTITUDE.
I COME FROM A REALLY FUN FAMILY.
I WAS LOOK AT LIFE LIKE WE ARE
ALWAYS IN THE FUND BUSINESS.
TO BE SERIOUS.
IF YOU DIED TOMORROW, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO WISH YOU GOT ONE MORE
TWITTER FIGHT.
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO LISTEN
TO THE SONG YOU LIKE, EAT THE
FOOD YOU LIKE.
THAT'S MY MENTALITY.
WHEN I WAS IN A CAB GETTING CUT
OFF AND SHOT AT, I WOULD BE
LIKE, I LOVE THIS SONG.
I'M NOT EVEN KIDDING.
THAT'S MY ONLY SECRET SAUCE IN
LIFE.
IF YOU LOOK AT LIFE LIKE YOUR
DOG WITH THE JOB.
THE DOG IS ALWAYS WAITING HIS
TAIL.
HE GOADED THE AIRPORT.
THEY ARE COUNTING ON HIM TO SAVE
THE PLANE.
THAT'S M